personne ne peut parler de chiffres
exacts mais un objectif qui est
parfaitement atteignable qui aura une
signification politique importante c'est
que nous restions le deuxième groupe du
sénat je pense que c'est ce que c'est ce
qui va se passer parce que la campagne
se passe très bien c'est un objectif
réalisable pour vous le deuxième groupe
du sénat
bien entendu alors les hamonistes à ont
menacé on l'a vu un le parti socialiste
de présenter une liste dissidente à
paris
finalement ça va pas être le cas marie
noëlle lienemann aile reste bien en
position éligible quatrième sur votre
liste en tous les cas
n'avez vous jamais prévu autre chose et
une liste qui a été discuté et validé
par les militants où il y avait un
ordonnancement n'a jamais été question
pour nous de bouger les ordres dans le
dos des militants à la veille d'un des
polices et des méthodes qui n'existe
plus au parti socialiste depuis que nous
investissons nous débattons et le bsc
sont donc moins menacés qu'avant l'été
par la république en marche
oui et non c'est à dire que de toute
façon nous savions que la vague qui
apporte emmanuel macron à la présidence
puis qui lui a donné une majorité aux
législatives n'était pas envisageable en
termes de réplique immédiate aux
sénatoriales puisque les sénatoriales
sont quand même essentiellement le fruit
de l'élection municipale de 2014 et des
équilibres politiques donc bien entendu
en marche existe et existera au sénat
mais ça
ne pouvait pas atteindre en plus la
façon dont tu l'étais s'est passé et les
mesures annoncées par le gouvernement au
pouvoir annoncer ou prises qui touche de
plein fouet les collectivités
territoriales et notamment cette
dernière annoncée sur la suppression des
emplois aidés qui permettait à des
collectivités à des associations à ce
qu'il faut vivre le tissu social local
et territorial de n'avoir plus les
moyens souvent de pouvoir même faire
parfois des rentrées scolaires
donc cela ajouté aux baisses de coûts
baisse drastique des financements des
collectivités locales annoncées est déjà
prise tout cela fait beaucoup
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
etc alors donc pour l'électorat qui qui
ne se range pas forcément derrière
l'étiquette qu'il avait au moment des
municipales il en existe bien entendu et
qui réagissent en fonction de leurs
réalités locales et de leurs enjeux
immédiats et actuelle on ne peut on peut
penser quand même que le gouvernement
d'edouard philippe a beaucoup déçu et va
être combattus dans les urnes